all eyes on Miami tonight as our
favorite Democratic candidates finally
get into the ring to slug it out over
the issues the first of a two night
debates split between 20 candidates and
president Trump thinks this one's going
to be Low Energy
everyone said I'll be tweeting I'll
actually be in a plane and it just seems
very boring but I'm gonna watch it
because I have to best part of my life
you know it's part of my life do I want
to watch it do I want to watch these
people that's a very unexcited group of
people each of us has come up with a
prediction for tonight's debate and I'll
go first so I predict there's going to
be audience interference some heckler
some screaming panting some chess
something where the audience member or
members try to interrupt and cause a
scene and they're gonna have to be
handled all right Katie you're next
everybody's going to get a free car and
you're right just kidding they'll say
that you're gonna get that I think John
Delaney will go after other Democrats so
be one of the few who does because he's
the more moderate and he's been saying
in speeches that socialist policies are
bad for the party and bad for the
country and he will get booed and he'll
get booed maybe some audience
interference then I predict there will
be zero questions about late term
abortion know also 1g I guess that's a
that would be a Republican debate Katie
anyway I think it's obviously a big
night for Elizabeth Warren she's the
only one on stage
who's polling in double digits but I in
terms of the other people I think it's
pretty clear that you're gonna have who
Leon Castro
really show up I think this is a in
Miami Hispanic audience on Telemundo I
think there's gonna be a lot of
opportunity for him to shine and I think
the second thing and this goes back to
what Kate you're saying I think the big
surprise is here let's talk about Trump
more talk about policies and so much
some people may say that's boring but I
think they're going to distinguish
themselves and like someone may say to
Elizabeth Warren could be Delaney could
be Amy Klobuchar how are you gonna pay
for that
oh all right that could be interesting
then all right I have one that I think
that better O'Rourke will raise a
million dollars after tonight's debate
what and get a second wind
because he'll do so well because he's
been laying low you know he's got
something right he but he didn't get all
the way
to the Ted Cruz race as he did with what
did he face of it it was fifty million
dollars eighty million dollars he has a
following he I think that he could find
a way to get a second wind oh I like
that prediction definitely a possibility
I predict not a second wind but a broken
wind I have three predictions that
Wayfair just like your om T's you can't
stick to one the Wade Barrett will
provide beds to anyone watching this
debate including half the participants
also I prediction for the audience that
they will have a hard time telling the
difference ideology ideologically
between the candidates and the
moderators because we know it's all one
flavor of leftism and finally my bold
prediction that's here bado will
accidentally take out someone's eye with
a flailing elbow use his million dollars
Elizabeth Warren who's far ahead in the
polls compared to the other people who
are gonna be on that stage I think she's
gonna be asked about her Indian heritage
and I think she has to be you don't
think so no I do
you don't think one of the moderators is
gonna say you know one of the things
that the president likes to say how are
you gonna handle this you don't think
she's gonna be asked about I do I don't
it would be the daughter I think she has
to have a different answer
I think she has and I'm gonna give her
some advice because she has to flip it
back on to the president she has to say
the president is obsessed with my family
tree and I care about families being
separate at the border that's how she
has to do it nice right now
what do you bother that's a great line
that is I think it's a better line it's
a better line than what she has been
saying which is that's a story
tonight to shine would you agree I think
it is her it's yeah a night to shine but
I usual to you said yes
here's the thing she will make it to the
second debate right one of the things
that the Democrats have done the DNC has
done is said to get to this first debate
you had to have 65,000 small donors
right to get to the next debate you have
to have a hundred and thirty thousand
you need momentum so she probably will
be able to do that I think many of the
others are not going to be able to make
that so otherwise yes you are people in
July by the way Jesse what you know I
think that when you're talking about the
advice you're giving her it just reminds
me I think you want a debate that's more
like the Republican debate I do little
little Marco lion tax I want sharp
exchanges that's what not gonna be bored
by policy on building your expectations
are gonna yeah a little let Greg
yesterday you I mean I mean you said
that you weren't gonna watch are you
standing by the no I'm gonna watch the
curt's here is that there because
there's so many people and their time is
limited how can you make an ass of
yourself it's gonna be really hard for
this people to make it they do have less
time to marshal one candidate to go up
against an already mobilized Trump so
that you could end up with that
plurality problem where it's us all
somebody needs this much to become the
nominee to run right they run out of
money to run it could happen because
there's not enough time people could say
something without enough context and
that will be taken out of context the
key is not that exciting so I agree with
you on that the key is introducing
yourself most people don't know these
folks know all right it's game tonight
or tomorrow yeah it's at nine o'clock
everybody so try to stay awake